PROFESSOR: So what I want to
talk about in today's lecture
is a strand in the philosophical
tradition that
looks not at the ways in which
human interconnectedness can
provide meaning and the
possibility for flourishing,
but which looks rather at a
certain sort of psychological
detachment as a way of dealing
with the inevitable
vicissitudes of lived
experience.
And the clearest articulation
of the outlook that we'll be
considering today in the
context of the Western
tradition can be found
in the writing of
the philosopher Epictetus.
Here's a wonderful imaginary
portrait of him from 1715,
sitting at a table, famously
with his cane, which he used
to walk as the result
of his limp.
As you know from the reading
guide, Epictetus lived at the
beginning of two
millennia ago.
He lived roughly from 50 to
130 in the common era.
He was born in Greek-speaking
Asia Minor, and spent his life
living in the Roman Empire
during that era.
He spent the early portion of
his life as a slave. There's
some dissent as to whether he
spent it until the age of
thirteen or until the age of
twenty seven, but in any case,
a significant portion of his
life was spent in slavery.
But he eventually gained
freedom, and at some point,
either before or after gaining
freedom, he studied the works
and philosophical outlook of a
tradition known as Stoicism.
And the works that were produced
on his behalf that
have survived are two.
The first is a major four
volume collection of his
discussions of a range of
topics: questions in
metaphysics, questions about
the way the world is,
questions in epistemology--how
we should understand the
world--and also questions
in ethics.
And in addition to that has
survived the extraordinary
book that we read for today.
The little forty-five epigraph
essay known as The Handbook,
which was, as in the case of
Aristotle, apparently recorded
by one of Epictetus's students
and preserved in that way.
Now, the work that Epictetus
produced in the context of The
Handbook was enormously
influential for most of the
two thousand years that
it has been part
of the Western tradition.
In particular, the frontispiece
that I used to
show you a picture of Epictetus
is drawn from the
library of none other than
John Adams, the second
president of the United States,
who had this book in
his collection in its
1715 Latin edition.
(Wait until the eclipse
passes.)
Another interesting thing to
know, historically, about the
volume that we're reading is
that the first English
translation of it was, in
fact, done by a great
eighteenth century woman of
letters, Elizabeth Carter.
Though the translation that
we're reading is a more modern
version of it.
So in this work, Epictetus takes
on many of the tenets of
classical stoicism.
So we've been introduced in this
class so far first to the
writings of Plato, who is a
systematic philosopher.
He has views about everything,
and his commitments are to a
certain kind of rationalist,
formalist, idealist
philosophy.
And we've been introduced to the
work of Aristotle through
one of his writings, the
Nichomachean Ethics.
But alongside those two
traditions, the Platonic
tradition and the Aristotelian
tradition, the ancient
philosophical world produced a
number of other systematic
philosophical outlooks--outlooks
that had
views about almost any question
you could ask.
And among those was the view
known as Stoicism.
So Stoics held, with respect to
the underlying metaphysical
facts about reality, that the
world itself is an organic
physical totality that's
governed by what they called
logos or divine reason.
There is an order
to the world.
And that the responsibility of
human beings, given that
order, is to cultivate a
particular kind of virtue.
Virtue on the Stoic picture is
acting in accord with what
reason tells you
nature demands.
It's going along with this grand
scheme of things, and
not trying to fight against what
is predivined for you.
So it's not surprising that
elements of the Stoic
tradition get picked up
in subsequent theistic
traditions.
In some ways, the Stoic view
that the world is a
well-ordered entity governed by
divine reason lies at the
heart of many of the religious
traditions that are familiar
to you today.
The question, then, becomes,
what is demanded of you
prescriptively?
What should you do if these
two things are the case?
And what the Stoics suggest is
that you need to accept your
fate, that it is the consequence
of the power and
goodness of the logos, even
though the ways in which it is
good for you may be unavailable
to you to see, and
that in order to do so, you need
to moderate your desires,
you need to avoid excess
emotion, and thereby come to
act in accord with reason.
So the contemporary use of the
term Stoic, one who doesn't
express suffering in the face of
pain, is picking up on the
second of these prescriptive
aspects.
But it's important to recognize
that as with all of
the philosophers that we're
reading, this is part of a
systematic worldview.
The idea is not, we pick a
little bit here and a little
bit there and we don't worry
about how they go together.
The idea is we have an idea
about the fundamental nature
of reality, a view about how we
know that, and then views
about what we ought to
do as a consequence.
Now, Epictetus, in The Handbook,
is concerned only
with a small portion of
the Stoic picture.
He's concerned, basically, with
writing the very first
self-help manual.
He's trying to tell you, Mr.
or Ms. Citizen of ancient
Roman world in about the year
100, what to do if you would
like to flourish.
And here's what he tells
you need to do.
You need to learn how to respond
appropriately to
experience by doing
three things.
You need to alter your
perceptions of the world so
that you come to apprehend
things in such a way that they
don't influence you harmfully.
You need to alter your desires
with respect to the world.
And you need to structure your
life in such a way that you
stay on the straight and narrow:
you need to structure
your social relations in ways
that will help you sustain
your commitments.
And in the next slide, in an
attempt to help you read
through the text that we have,
I suggested ways of putting
each of the subpassages of the
book into one of these
categories.
So, for example, when Epictetus
tells us that we
need alter our perception of
the world, there are three
specific ways that he thinks
we might go about doing it;
three components to
this instruction.
The first is that we need to
properly classify things into
two categories: things over
which we have control-- and
we'll talk more about
that in a moment--
and things over which we
don't have control.
So we need to get our
taxonomy down.
We need also to anticipate
the way the
world typically unfolds.
So we need not only to know
what is up to us and what
isn't up to us, but among the
things that aren't up to us,
we need to structure our
expectations in such a way
that we are emotionally
prepared for
what will befall us.
And again, I'll talk
more about that
in a couple of slides.
And we need to recognize--
in some ways this is a subpoint
of the first--
the role that judgment and
choice play in determining
whether it is the case that
experiences affect us.
So those are the three things
that Epictetus says we need to
do with respect to perception,
and again, I'll give examples
of each of them in a moment.
In addition, we'll go on
to the second thing
that we need to do.
He tells us that we need to
cultivate appropriate desires.
We need to get our desires lined
up with the world in
such a way that we aren't
subject repeatedly to
frustration.
And the way we do this is by
inverting the standard
relation between desire
and the world.
Usually, desires express a
way things aren't, but
you wish they were.
I desired firmly yesterday that
there not be the eighth
snow day in three weeks
for my children.
But the world refused to
cooperate on that question.
Had I instead adjusted my
desires to the world--
I desired that things go on
exactly as logos predicts--
then I would have been
content with their
presence in my office.
The second thing that Epictetus
tells us we can do
in strategizing how to cultivate
appropriate desires
is to make use of this
extraordinary human capacity
to assimilate things
from one category
to things from another.
So remember when I showed you
the Wason selection task, that
funny thing which had an A, and
an F, and a 4, and a 7,
and I asked which card we had
to turn over to determine
whether it was true that if
there's an A on one side,
there's a 7 on the other.
Doing that task was hard, but
when I showed you that it was
structurally identical to
another task, the task of
being shown four cards which
had ages and alcoholic or
nonalcoholic drinks, and I asked
you, which cards do you
need to turn over to verify the
truth of, if somebody is
drinking a beer, then
she is over 21.
All of a sudden, you were able
to understand the difficult
problem in light of the problem
with respect which you
had traction.
Epictetus points out to us that
we have a skill set for
letting go.
We have a skill set for
psychological distancing.
We have a skill set
for saying, "Hah!
Stuff happens, and it
doesn't matter".
And what he suggests we do,
and again, I'll give an
example of this, is to learn how
to assimilate the things
which we find hard to let go of
to the things which we find
easy to let go of, and thereby
exploit this capacity that we
have for metaphoric
understanding.
Finally in this category,
Epictetus points out the
importance of habituating
yourself to the
inevitability of loss.
Here's some bad news
for all of you.
You're going to die.
Shelly Kagan has an entire
course about this, about
coming to terms with
this inevitable
fact about human existence.
But Epictetus suggests that
by taking this on board
profoundly, in a way affects you
not just at the level of
being able to utter the words,
"I will die someday," but at
the level of really habituating
it to your
relations to things.
All of a sudden, things that
seemed incredibly important
loom less so.
Finally, Epictetus points out
the importance, if you're
going to act in ways that run
counter to the norms of your
culture, the importance of
realizing that you're going to
get negative social feedback.
So passage after passage
describes the importance of
resisting social pressure.
When people say of
you, "You aren't
seeking honor and glory!
You must be a loser!" Epictetus
says, "Let them say
so, and care not what they say
about you." And as I point out
here, there are almost
fifteen passages that
identify this strategy.
Finally, Epictetus gives you a
kind of trick, a persona that
he wants you to cultivate.
You're supposed to be a kind
of silent type: people say
stuff, and you just calmly
don't respond.
So this strategy that he's
presenting to us has these
three main parts.
And what I want to do in the
next bit of lecture is to run
through some specific examples
of this, looking first at
Epictetus's text, quoting it
directly, and then suggesting
some contemporary analogues for
what it is that Epictetus
is talking about.
So the opening paragraph of
Epictetus's handbook is one of
the most famous bits of
philosophical writing in the
Western tradition of the
last 2000 years.
It begins as follows.
"Some things are up to us and
some things are not up to us.
Our opinions are up to us, and
our impulses, our desires, our
aversions--
in short, whatever
is our own doing.
But our bodies are not up to
us, that is, the physical
parts of ourselves, nor our
possessions, our reputations,
our public offices, whatever
is not our own doing."
Now he's going to go
on and point out a
mistake you can make.
"The things that are up to
us are by nature free,
unhindered, and unimpeded,
whereas the things that are
not up to us are naturally
enslaved,
hindered, and not our own.
But if you think that things
that are naturally enslaved,
things that are not up to you,
are your own, if you think
things naturally enslaved are
free, or that things that are
not your own are your own, you
will be thwarted, miserable,
upset..." and walking around
blaming the world for
everything that's going
wrong with you.
The mistake of confusing that
over which you have control
and that over which you lack
control leads to thwarted,
upset, miserable, blamingness.
By contrast, keeping these
categories straight brings the
greatest prize: "If you think
that only what is yours is
yours, and that what is not your
own is not your own, then
no one will ever coerce you, no
one will ever hinder you.
You will blame no one.
You will not accuse anyone.
You will do not a single thing
unwillingly..." because the
only things over which you seek
to have control are the
things over which you
do have control.
And as a consequence, "no one
can coerce you," because
you're only concerned about the
things that are up to you.
"No one can hinder you," because
nobody can get in the
way of the things that
are up to you.
Now, any of you who has
experience with a friend or
relative or an acquaintance who
has taken part in one of
the many contemporary versions
of Epictetus in the form of a
self-help program knows that
at the heart of the
contemporary twelve step
tradition lies a version of
this Epictetan thought,
articulated in prayer form,
most likely first by
Reinhold Niebuhr.
And that is the serenity prayer,
which you can find
decorated with hummingbirds
and daffodils--
"God grant me the serenity to
accept the things I cannot
change, courage to change the
things I can't, and wisdom to
know the difference." If morning
glories aren't your
style, you can find it
decorated with a dog.
Or an angel.
Or a young child.
You can find it on a bowl, or,
most strikingly, you can find
it tattooed upon your arm, or
your thigh, or your side.
So clearly, there is something
in the Epictetan picture that
speaks to the contemporary
mind.
And speaks to it in a way that
when I did a Google image
search for "serenity prayer,"
I found thousands and
thousands of images like
this in any language
you can think of.
So this idea that we need to
distinguish between things
that we can change and things
that we can't, and that an
attitude of acceptance is what's
appropriate towards
things that we can't change,
whereas an attitude of effort
is what's appropriate towards
things that we can, is a
lesson that Epictetus
has offered
to the Western tradition.
Second example.
Epictetus talks to us about the
importance of emotional
regulation through anticipating
what will happen
to you in a particular
setting.
So he says, suppose you are
going to go to the baths.
When you are about to take some
sort of action, he says,
remind yourself what sort
of action it is.
"You're going to take a bath?
Put before your mind what
happens at baths!
There are people who splash,
there are people who jostle,
there are people who are
insulting." If you're going to
go to the airport, remember,
you're going to have to wait
in a long line.
If you're prepared for the fact
that you're going to be
sitting there, needing to wait
for your ticket, you can
adjust your emotions.
"Say to yourself, I want to take
a bath." I want to go to
the airport.
I want to walk across campus
on the icy sidewalks.
"I want to do so in a way that
keeps my choices in accord
with nature." If you
appropriately expect things to
be as they are, then you
will not be frustrated.
I want to walk across campus.
It's an icy day.
I realize that in walking across
campus on an icy day,
I'll need to slide my feet
rather than lift them.
That which had previously been
an annoyance comes to be a
fact about the world which
is not up to me, and
consequently, something
which does not perturb
my feeling of calm.
Third thing Epictetus suggests
we do is to recognize that
what is upsetting to us are not
things that happen, but
rather our judgments
about those things.
And you recall when I showed
you that image from the
Metropolitan Museum of
Socrates's death upon drinking
the hemlock, and told you that
a death done with nobility,
recorded by a good PR
agent--something true both of
Socrates and of a carpenter from
Nazareth--in such cases,
one can serve as a touchstone
for people's thought about how
to deal with human life and
its inevitabilities.
So Epictetus says, what upsets
people are not things, but
their judgments about
those things.
For example, "death in itself,"
he says, "must be
nothing dreadful.
For if it were dreadful, then
Socrates, the great wise one,
would have felt it to be
dreadful." What's scary about
death, says Epictetus,
is not death itself.
What is dreadful about death
is the judgment about death
that it is dreadful.
Nothing is harmful in itself.
It's up to you whether
you let it harm you.
When you teach your children
not to be upset by the
thoughtless taunts of their
classmates, what you point out
to them is, what their
classmates say about them
can't hurt them unless
it's emotionally
disturbing to them.
If you don't let it hurt
you, it can't hurt you.
And we find voice given to
this-- here's Laurence Olivier
playing Hamlet--
in the famous Rosencranz and
Guildenstern scene of Hamlet,
which I put up here for you,
because I understand that
there's a production of Hamlet
happening in one of the
colleges in a couple of weeks.
So Hamlet is in conversation
with these two emissaries, and
complaining about what a rotten
place Denmark is, and
they disagree.
They say, Denmark doesn't
strike us as so bad, and
famously, Hamlet says back, "Why
then, 'tis none to you!
For there is nothing either good
or bad but thinking makes
it so."
When you walk around
the world, things
have shape and sizes.
This table is rectangular.
These walls are white.
The temperature is
such and such.
These are facts about
the world.
Things in the world don't have
valences attached to them.
It's not attached to an event
that it is good or bad.
It is your assessment
of the event that
gives it that valence.
That's the third Epictetan
point.
Fourth point.
Epictetus points out
that there are two
ways of having desires.
One can, on the one hand, ask
the world to conform to what
you want, or one can ask
what you want to
conform to the world.
Epictetus favors the second.
"Do not want to have events
happen to you as you want them
to, but instead, want them to
happen as they do happen, and
your life will go well.
Here's a way to get a 100%
guarantee that you'll
get what you want.
Want what you get.
If you want what you get, you
will get what you want.
So contemporary philosophy has
a way of describing this.
And one of the ways of thinking
about it--they use
this notion that they call
direction of fit --is to think
about what a shopping list is.
So because I had some parchment
left over from that
contract that we signed with the
devil a few weeks ago, I
thought I'd use it for my
shopping list. So here I am,
unenlightened by Epictetus,
and I write on my shopping
like that I would like apples,
broccoli, and lemons.
And so I go to the store, and
the fulfillment of my desire
depends upon there being apples,
broccoli, and lemon.
You, enlightened by Epictetus,
go to the store, look and see
what's there, pull out your
parchment paper, and make your
list. Apples, broccoli,
and lemons.
So far there's no difference
between us, even though your
strategy was to shape your
desire to fit the world, and
my strategy was to
try to shape the
world to fit my desire.
But what happens to us when the
store is out of broccoli?
I have on my list apples,
broccoli, and lemons.
But there is no broccoli.
I'm set up for frustration.
You, by contrast, conform your
desires to the world.
You want what you get.
So you change your shopping
list, and everything is fine.
The Epictetan idea here is that
if you shape your desires
to the way things actually
are, you will never be
frustrated.
Fourth suggestion.
Fourth?
Fifth?
One of you must be
keeping count.
Proper perspective.
So Epictetus offers this
extraordinary analogy in
paragraph seven.
He says, "On a voyage when your
boat has anchored, if you
want to get fresh water, you may
pick up a small shellfish
and a vegetable by the way.
But you must keep your mind
fixed on the boat, and look
around frequently, in case
the captain calls.
If he calls, you must let all
those other things go, so you
will not be tied up and on
the ship like livestock."
The idea is, sure, go around,
enjoy stuff in the world, but
don't let yourself get
attached to it.
When a major priority occurs,
keep things in
order in your mind.
"But," he continues, "This is
how it is in life." You know
how to relate to shellfish
and tomatoes.
"This is how it is in life,
too." I'm quoting again.
"If you are given a wife and a
child, instead of a vegetable
and a small shellfish, that
should not hinder you either.
But if the captain calls, let
all things go and run to the
boat without turning back." Take
the strategies that you
have available for you for
dealing with things whose
transience you recognize, and
adopt those attitudes towards
things who's transience
is painful to you.
"When your jug breaks," he says,
"you say: That is but a
broken jug.
When your child is lost, say:
That is but a lost child."
This is the logical consequence
of the outlook
that I've been presenting
to you from Epictetus.
It sounded really good when it
was the serenity prayer.
It sounded pretty good
at the grocery store.
It sounds pretty disturbing when
it's the wife and child.
What is it that's going on?
I leave that for you as a
question, and turn now to the
second text that we read for
today, a great work composed
in the sixth century, in around
524, by somebody whose
life trajectory went almost
invertedly to the way that
Epictetus's did.
Epictetus, you'll recall, was
born a slave, and tried to
make sense of his life
experience of suffering once
he became free.
Boethius, by contrast, was born
into a noble family, was
enormously successful
politically in his early
years, had two sons who went on
to be enormously successful
political figures.
And in his later years, was
imprisoned for treason.
And because The Consolation of
Philosophy was one of the most
widely read and reproduced
works of its era--
it was read for centuries and
centuries by almost everyone--
we have gorgeous illuminated
manuscripts
that show us the story.
So in this one, here's Boethius
beforehand, teaching
people, and here he is
afterwards, locked up in jail.
Now in jail, in prison, where he
is tortured and suffering,
Boethius consoles himself by
engaging in an imaginary
conversation with a figure
that he calls Philosophy.
So here is Philosophy, come to
visit Boethius in his prison.
And what Philosophy says to
him is, in many ways, like
what Epictetus was
talking about.
There is, she says, a
wheel of fortune.
Sometimes things start off
badly and get better.
better and get bad.
But there will inevitably be a
circle to what comes to you
and to what is taken from you.
And recognizing that there is
nothing to be done, other than
to recognize that this is the
pattern that life takes, is,
to Boethius, enormously
liberating.
Recognizing that what goes along
with having things is
the possibility of losing them
allows him to come to terms
with the experience of
having lost all that
he previously had.
What I want to do in the final
section of the lecture is to
return to a theme that we
discussed previously, the
question of what philosophical
utility there is to these
works during times of
extreme duress.
So my hope, because you read an
essay by him, is that even
if you don't recognize this
gentleman, you can
guess who he is.
This is Admiral James Stockdale,
who was, among
other things, imprisoned
alongside John McCain in Hanoi
during the Vietnam War, and
who was also the Vice
Presidential candidate running
on the independent ticket, I
understand, before
you were born.
So James Stockdale, as he
explains to you in the
incredibly moving memoir that we
read for today, studied the
works of the classical
tradition.
He read Epictetus.
He read a bunch of
the other Stoics.
He read the Iliad.
He read the Odyssey.
And all of these were part of
his cognitive and emotional
repertoire when, in Vietnam,
the following
thing happened to him.
"It was September 9, 1965." I'm
reading now from his book.
"I flew at 500 knots right into
a flak trap at treetop
level in a little A4 airplane,
the cockpit walls not even
three feet apart, which
I couldn't steer
after it was on fire.
Its control system shot out.
After ejection, I had thirty
seconds to make my last
statement of freedom before I
landed in the main street of a
little village right ahead, and
so help me, I whispered to
myself, 'Five years down here.
At least I'm leaving the world
of technology, and entering
the world of Epictetus.'
"Ready at hand," he said, now
quoting from The Handbook,
"Ready at hand from the
Enchiridion, The Handbook, as
I ejected from that airplane,"
was that opening paragraph
that we read a few
moments ago.
"The understanding that a Stoic
always keeps separate
files in his mind for A, those
things that are up to him, and
B, those things that
are not up to him.
Another way of saying this,"
says Stockdale, "is those
things that are within his
power, and those things that
are beyond his power.
Still another way
of saying it.
Those things that are within
the grasp of his free will,
and those that lie beyond it."
All of the things over which
you do not have control,
which, in the contact of
tortured imprisonment, are a
huge number, are external.
And, says Stockdale, it will
doom me to fear and anxiety if
I covet them.
I need to let go of
the thought that
those things will change.
However--and this is
crucial--everything in
category A is up to me.
Within my power, within my will,
and those are the things
that are properly subject
for my total concern and
involvement.
These matters include my
opinions, my aims, my
aversions, my grief, my joy,
my judgments, my attitude
about what is going on, my
own good, my own evil.
"My internal character," says
Stockdale, "in circumstances
which are almost unimaginably
difficult.
My character and my response to
those things are up to me."
And he goes on to describe the
experience of torture using a
trope that we've seen
repeatedly in
the texts we've read.
He says, "When tortured, and
released from the torture,
what we contemplated was that
we had engaged in a certain
sort of betrayal of ourselves
and what we stood for.
It was there that I learned
what Stoic harm"--
echoes of the moral harm that
we talked about when we
discussed the Jonathan
Shay work--
"a shoulder broken, a bone in
my back broken, a leg broken
twice, were peanuts
in comparison."
Epictetus: "Look not for any
greater harm than this
destroying the trustworthy,
self-respecting, well-behaved
man inside you." Situations of
extremity that force people to
discover in themselves aspects
of what they are capable that
they don't wish to see, are
what is most harmful.
When Plato says, "It will do
you no good to gain gold by
selling or enslaving
your daughter.
Why, then, gain gold by selling
or enslaving your
soul?", he's expressing the
thought that we hear here.
When we read in the discussions
of Jonathan Shay
about the experience of feeling
that one has betrayed
what one stood for--
that is what led to a feeling
of moral harm.
And when Milgram's subjects
found themselves doing things
that they felt repulsive to
them, they shivered, they
shook, they felt a disorder
in their soul.
Here, again, is an answer
to Glaucon's challenge.
But notice that though Stockdale
is taking on board
much of the Epictetan picture,
he's rejecting the bit about
the tomato and the wife.
That is, he rejects in Epictetus
the idea that social
relations aren't important.
In the paragraph following the
one that I just read to you,
he writes as follows.
"When people are released from
solitary confinement, when put
back in a regular cell block,
hardly an Americans came out
of that experience without
responding something like
this, when first whispered to
by a fellow prisoner next
door. 'You don't want
to talk to me.
I am a traitor.' But," says
Stockdale, doing this sort of
listening whose importance Shay
emphasized in our reading
for last week, "But because we
were equally fragile, it
seemed to catch on that we all
replied something like this.
'Listen, pal.
There are no virgins here.
You should have heard the kind
of statement I made.
Snap out of it.
We're all in it together.
What's your name?
Tell me about yourself.'"
To hear that last, to hear that
you are accepted and that
there are others around you
willing to listen to the
experience which you found
painful, was for, I'm now
quoting again, "most new
prisoners just out of initial
shakedown and cold soak, a
turning point in their lives."
So the question that Stockdale's
text raises for us
is the question of whether it is
possible for us to take on
board some of the Epictetan
picture without
taking on all of it.
Is it possible to regulate our
desires so that we don't
expect more from the world that
it's possible to get, but
to do so in such a way that
we don't thereby lose the
possibilities for the most
profound types of human
connectedness?
To that, I don't know the
answer, but I think it's worth
thinking about as a question.
I look forward to seeing many of
you at 2:30 this afternoon.
Are there questions?
We have a minute.